Багато продуктів на Сході ЄС на смак зовсім інші,
ніж у західних країнах-членах спільноти –
такого висновку нібито дійшло дослідження
міністерства сільського господарства Угорщини.
Мовляв, "кола" зроблена з дешевого кукурудзяного сиропу,
намазка на хліб не така ніжна,
а шоколад тане в роті значно повільніше.
Усього є претензії до майже сотні продуктів.
Споживачі їх охоче підтверджують.
Я не експертка, але впевнена,
що німецький пральний порошок,
який я купую в Австрії, пере краще, ніж куплений тут.
Коли я купую бензин за кордоном,
то авто споживає значно менше.
Та й солодощі там солодші, ніж у нас.
В Угорщині питання взяли на контроль
на найвищому політичному рівні.
Речник уряду навіть пообіцяв нове розслідування.
Ми ухвалимо рішення щодо подальших кроків
проти виробників та продавців цих продуктів.
Можливо, ми залучимо до цього і Брюссель.
Під прицілом критики опинився і німецький виробник Ritter Sport.
В Угорщині йому закидають,
що шоколад не так швидко тане в роті.
При цьому всі шоколадки для понад 150 країн
виробляють лише в одному місці –
у Вальденбуху поблизу Штутгарта.
Хіба що упаковка дещо відрізняється залежно від країни експорту.
Так для Угорщини на німецькомовну обгортку шоколадки
наклеюють наліпку угорською.
Тож звинувачення з Угорщини тут взагалі не розуміють.
Нам, як виробнику високої якості, дуже прикро,
особливо з огляду на філософію нашого підприємства про те,
що наш смак однаковий у всьому світі.
Так, це неприємно.
Утім, повернімося до Угорщини.
На місцевому ринку харчових продуктів домінують західні концерни.
В угорських виробників майже немає шансів
потрапити у великі супермаркети.
Типовий приклад - мале підприємство Choko Me,
яке спеціалізується на виготовленні
високоякісного шоколаду для гурманів.
Ми надто маленькі і не маємо такого потенціалу.
Нам просто бракує грошей,
щоб рухатися в цьому напрямку.
Тому й доводиться виробляти в малій кількості.
Чи дійсно настільки різняться смаки
або якість продуктів на Сході й на Заході Європи,
наразі достеменно не відомо.
Однак після гучних звинувачень
Угорщині доведеться надати конкретні докази.